welcome to the dark side we got cookies
and a presentation about making dark
mode accessible for web
i'm angry from iran and i've been an
ember volunteer since 2018 ember conf
i'm the person in the zoe costume so
if you were there back then you might
have heard me
i've given lightning talks at ember fest
and talks at emerconf before
i married nick schrotz in
august making my name even longer and
more comp complicated for everybody
outside of the netherlands
and i work in krullo
at nada
a company that does a lot of things and
i work there as a team coach where i
help teams communicate and collaborate
you can find me all over social media on
instagram twitter
github and of course on the amber
discord
let's get back on topic
making dark mode accessible for web
first we're going to talk about how to
make it accessible for you as a
developer to implement the preferences
for dark modes or light modes within
your website
secondly we're going to talk about how
to make it accessible for the user who's
actually looking at your web page
when we're talking about dark mode and
light mode the first thing that comes
into mind for developers
is editors
here we see an example of the light mode
and dark mode themes from visual studio
code
css tricks did a poll to check what the
preferences of developers actually are
and they found out that 37 of
the their respondents
actually prefers
light mode over dark mode so it's
actually a matter of taste and maybe it
differs from situation to situation
but what about the web
luckily in the web we can also cater to
the preferences of our users and i did
so during oktoberfest 2021 for two ember
projects and i want to take you through
how i did it for both of them
the first project is the alfy automation
tracker by mel sumner
you can see it here it has a great list
of all potential accessibility
violations that we might run into later
and now you can also look at it in a
dark mode
the background got dark gray and we
changed the purplish accent color to be
yellow
the violations page with a ton of rows
and columns
and start status
status indications
is now dark gray
alternating rose with darker colors to
make sure that the contrast of the
status in
locations still adheres to the wicked
standards
the second project that i did was the
lint to the future dashboard that chris
already talked about today
he told you how it works i'm just here
to talk about the design
we changed the light green and the
white cards
to a dark blue and a lighter blue for
the cards to match the blue of the
buttons that was already there
we actually did these two using media
queries in our css files so we're not
even bothered with javascript at this
point
a media query is the part of your css
file that starts with add media followed
by
sometimes a little and sometimes a lot
the first part of a media
query is the media's type there are
three types there is all print and
screen
all
makes it explicit that it will apply
always
print will make sure that it only
applies when a user is printing it
a screen will make sure that it only
applies when it's
watched on a screen
so for dark mode we're going to use
screen because when a user prints your
dark themed page it probably doesn't
want to print a whole black page with
some white letters in it
the second part of a media query is the
media feature
and there are a ton of them
they might look at the orientation of
your
device they might look at the width of
your device
but today we're going to look at the
media queries concerning preferences
because they are there and they allow
you to check what preferences your user
has
we're going to look at prefers color
scheme
this allows you to detect if the user
prefers a light or a dark color scheme
where light is the default
it will look like this if you actually
want to listen to the
dark
preference add media screen and to make
sure that we use them both
prefers color scheme dark
time to insert your css
but before we do that let's look at how
browsers support this and luckily
it's a lot this is the user's relative
so we see that most of our users will
probably be able to actually use this
feature
the way we intend to
when we're looking at the link to the
future dashboard we're looking at a
normal css project
this project
will has a normal css file where we
inject the add media prefers color
scheme dark
we're going to change the body color to
be the dark blue and make the text all
white
the second thing we do is change the
color of the link to be yellow to make
sure that the contrast between the blue
and the yellow is
great enough
where the green wouldn't have done that
we're changing the background color of
the chart
and here we're running into the first
real problem where we can hardly read
any of the access labels anymore so
we're also making those white
the axis labels are svg so that's why we
use fill
white
and we need to actually overwrite them
so that's why the important is there you
probably
don't really need that that often
if you want to do this in your own css
project
you
probably start out with a root with css
variables in it so we have two color css
variables and then we have the border
radius
we're gonna use those variables to
describe the background color of our
body and the back and the color of our
text
the next thing we're doing is creating
the media query for the dark
color scheme preferences and changing
the background color to a really dark
gray and the background text or the text
color tool wise
what we could do to even clean it up
more
is move
all the color variables into two
distinct
preferences preferred color schemes so
we're moving
the default ones to light and nor the
dark ones too dark this way you always
know where your colors are
so they're always where they supposed to
be in the color scheme preference
for the a11y automation tracker it works
a bit different
this project uses tailwind css which is
a css framework where you actually need
to enable the dark mode
feature
in the tailwind config
here you have the option to choose media
or class media works
with the media query as we just saw
class allows you to toggle
manually and use a class to do so
here we're using the media query
to have the same behavior as the link to
the future dashboard
tailwind
enables you to do
this
without
immediately changing something
to change something to your code you
actually need to
add the dark keyword
you're gonna add the dark keyword to in
front of a bunch of colors where you
actually want to change the color from
so here we're going to change the
background to dark background gray 700
which is telling tailwind that if a user
prefers a dark color scheme we're going
to use the dark gray instead of the gray
100 that is the default
changing these two projects to actually
adhere to the user preferences took me a
hundred lines of code
and i hope this has shown you how to do
it for your projects too
but this was all cool and designing but
what about the devices that your users
use their products on
maybe we're developing this on a super
high resolution 8k screen
and your user might use an old tablet
to make sure that our design is
universally accessible we're going to
take you through all the things that
might impact the design that you made on
your own computer they might use it
outside in the sun
reducing
uh maybe the contrast of your colors
they might use it at night
make uh making
the white of your screen and your design
way more impactful
users might not always perceive certain
colors because they
perceive a reduced contrast
they might not see certain colors or
they might not see any colors at all
agata has talked
about these last two and i hope you
learned a lot from her
about the topic of color blindness you
will see it come along in my talk but i
won't spend much time on it here
when we're thinking about how people
access the data
that our web app is providing we're
talking about the accessibility
often abbreviated to a 11 and y
on the web
and today i want to talk to you about
colors
colors are what makes a dark color
scheme a colors dark color scheme and
here i want to show you what happens if
we mix colors so here we're mixing paint
we're taking the primary colors red blue
and green
red blue and yellow and we're actually
mixing green orange and purple
when we mix them all together we get
brown
that works fine when you're painting
something but a lot of us don't paint
for our users we're designing for an led
screen an led screen uses a red a blue
and a green led to mix colors and as you
can see in this example we can't mix
brown
way but we can perceive brown
yes but it's a super dark orange
when it comes to printing
things get even more complex because
we're not using rgb values we're using
cymk values
so
colors across multiple medias
don't always work the same
i have been calling these colors red
blue and green
but you might observe them differently
you might not think that
salmon is pink
or that there's a distinction between
them because you as a male might observe
something different or call something
different than a female
it also is impacted by the culture
you're from there are languages that
have multiple words for the word blue
where i would just call it blue
so we've been talking about how we
make
colors how we talk about colors and then
there's of course how we perceive colors
for me the left pitch left top picture
is super distinct from the other three
but if you have a color deficiency you
might not see it the same way
luckily there are guidelines that tell
us
what we should do to make our website as
accessible as possible there are tools
out there to help you do so
so the web content accessibility
guidelines talk about contrast
when they talk about contrast they're
talking about a ratio so the ratio from
the darker color to the lighter color
and they have defined what ratio it
should adhere to
there's a lot of math behind it where
you can use relative luminance of one
the relative luminance of the other and
calculate it
i don't do that much math on my
day-to-day basis so there are things
like the web aim contrast checker that
allow you to put in the hex value
of your color foreground and background
and see what the contrast ratio is it
also allows you to adjust your color to
see when it passes
be aware that this number is a
mathematical number which probably
doesn't mean that it works on each
screen the same
so if you're
scooting it super close to the
accessibility guidelines cutoff point
you're probably not making it accessible
across all screens and devices
firefox allows you to hover over a color
and it will show you whether or not you
passed the color contrast
check
when we go back to the contrast checker
i've chosen two colors and i've not
picked them at random i've chosen a
super dark blue and a pink
and i'm specifically saying these names
for the color for the foreground and the
background because when we emulate that
the user doesn't see any red it changes
to a dark blue with a blue background at
least for me it has changed but contrast
checker did not update
luckily the accessibility tool in
firefox allows you to see what contrast
it now actually has and we can see that
it dropped
far below three so it doesn't adhere to
the contrast check anymore
so be aware that if you're trying to
make a universal design that works
across multiple devices across
different way of using and different
users you might not want to use always
these colors so distinctly
then we come to the last part
the tools that will actually help you to
create
a universally acceptable design
and they're across your browser that you
use from day to day
i took four browsers safari
the chromium-based browsers and firefox
because there are the big three and they
all have different tools to help you
make a universally acceptable design
when we look at
safari they have
two icons right on the elements tab
the first one doesn't print your page as
you might think but it will toggle to
the printed version of your page
so that you can see if your ad media
screen actually worked or if you're
using
a media print that it actually does what
it should the other icon behind it even
though it's not so clear what it does
will toggle to a dark mode for you so it
will forces dark mode
the second thing that they have are
accessibility audits the accessibility
audits there are a ton of them you can
run them on your website
i don't think they're
as useful as maybe
something we'll see later but i wanted
to show you you that they are there
the second part of the browser i want to
discuss are the chromium-based browsers
they use lighthouse to allow you to
generate for example an accessibility
report
for your website in this case we're
generating an accessibility report we're
getting a score
which is going to be 87 and we're going
to see which violations there are and
how we could fix them in this case we
see a contrast violation because the
orange
contrasting with the white is not enough
to pass the wicket test text test
we can also emulate
things like we did in safari but we have
to go through the three dots rendering
to make sure that we pick emulate live
mode preference or dark mode preference
we can also emulate uh the different
color vision
deficiencies there
they're a bit hidden so i hope that you
now know where to find them
in firefox we can toggle between light
and dark mode similarly to safari
although they have introduced two
buttons here so the sun is to force
light mode and the
moon is to force dark mode and then you
have to print option that doesn't look
like a printer but like a printed page
to do the same print toggle that i just
talked about in safari
the second part is the accessibility tab
that allows you to
again do kind of an accessibility audit
in this case on contrast and allows you
to on that
audit
emulate a certain column efficiency here
we're claiming to see no green
and with that we actually see that
a part of the color contrast violations
disappears because the blue we picked
had a lot of green in it making it
closer to white
by removing that green
we're actually getting a better contrast
this shows that not always color
deficiencies leads to a
lesser accessibility point but they
might increase the accessibility so make
sure that you test these things so you
can even enhance it for your other users
too
so what have we talked about today
well first of all we talked about how
you want to implement this in your css
file if you're using a normal css file
you're using the add media screen
and prefers color scheme dark
media query and you're going to insert
your color concerned css there
second of all you're going to use the
tools that different browsers provide
you
to
check if it actually works to check if
the contrast is okay to easily toggle
without having to go to your system
settings which i did before i found out
that these buttons were there
um
and then lastly i hope that while you're
designing your web app and you're
building your web app you're
thinking about
all the different devices and situations
that your users are in
thank you very much
you